bendy irwin is the proof we need that
life can still be good
even in 2020. she got married in april
and today
steve's little girl is celebrating her
birthday in a way that would certainly
make her dad proud
are you used to calling each other
husband and wife yet
we haven't really been able to say it to
many people everyone in the zoo kind of
knows so yeah we've said it to a lot of
animals
the 22 year old birthday girl and still
newlywed
is celebrating with this animal planet
cake and taking part in the family's
birthday tradition
feeding the crocs how is newlywed life
it has been a really funny time caring
for 1200 animals
you couldn't be more on brand of course
et first met bindi back in 2002
she was just three years old and daddy's
little girl
her name's bindi and we called it bindi
after the feistiest female crocodile
that i've got at my zoo
and she's like mowgli she's at one with
the animals who do you want to be when
you grow up bindi
just like my daddy just like her daddy
what's next well of course keeping steve
irwin's legacy alive
and maybe adding kind of a sexy spin on
zoo life
i thought about this you guys bendy and
chandler you fell in love with the zoo
steve and terry were in love there i
think you can
like do you have a cabin you should have
people be able to come and like stay and
like have a trip at the zoo can they do
that
like the bachelor but zoo edition
seats are being planted the most
dramatic zoo
experience ever